a desk with mom and dad's laptop this is
where Ozzy me and Aneesa ER nosy me
spend as much as six hours a day they
have a passion for programming a skill
they taught themselves by getting onto
the internet it started last year and
they had a really small phone at the
time so our google chrome wasn't really
functional for me so it says create
something that could work for myself so
we said start the browser when he said
once building your brother for myself I
thought I'll be cool say kind of tag
along an alien saw some food they call
their app the crocodile browser it uses
very little bandwidth and almost 60,000
people have already downloaded it that's
a strong incentive for an AC and Orsini
to keep improving their product the
boy's mother is proud but she's
insistent that they need to slow down
and pay attention to the rest of life we
have to plan this graph to balance its
you create sample program a great time
for school work you know you're still in
school you must finish school
the two are using the school holidays to
do an internship at talent accelerator
an educational startup in Lagos they can
continue developing their project here
they benefit from the experience of
other programmers and IT entrepreneurs
they've received lots of encouragement
from the program where councillors see
great promise in the brothers this guys
are two wonderful young people who have
shown some level of brilliance what
they've done with a coco delight browser
and yes it's not perfect yet was a very
nice idea and I believe as potential the
two young interns have learned that user
feedback is the key to improving their
browser an essay and orsina have already
received plenty of motivation along with
concrete ideas for additional features I
wanted to be like on every like
something I put every day like a
necessity for people
like we can't do and can't do anything
sizing google ask me like that when the
brothers would be as popular as any
mainstream product to use on your phone
like you said use google maps see if he
wants us to be that popular an AC is
going back to south africa where he'll
finish school by a smart phone and
laptop the two brothers will continue to
pursue their IT career together over the
internet